μας δίνεις προσκλήσεις ναι όι τον κόσμο για όσους μας παρακολουθούν θα υπάρχει διαγωνισμός μετά
προς κλήσεις για το όρστα ναι στεσόσιδύο θα έχουμε τοτο ίκοπι όλστακαι εείναι είναι πλέον
ένας θεσμός στα τελευταία ναδόδεκα χρόνια θα έχουμε έχουμεθα σας δώσουμε δύο προσκλήσεις οι οποίες
θα έχουν γιαδύο δηλεθεατέα σας που θα είναι μέσα στο κύπεο κόσις δκαι δύο στηνκυρκία
ακριβώς και κάποια δώρα τα οποια θα βάλουμε κύπαγω φανέλα της εθνικής κύπρου κασκόλ και
κάποια άλλα αντρία σε ευχαριστώ παραπολύ κάθε επιτυχία ευχαριστόπου έκλεισες και θέσύ το είδα για
το ευρόυπαέ το είμαστε κ οστηρίζουμε την εχμήαα ψ όλοι να στηρίξυμό την εθνικήγα τι
όπως είπες και σι τελευταίας έχει βάθος χείο όραμα και πρέπει να στηρικτί ευχαριστώολ σε
καλά κι εγώθα καλώ στο φίλες και φίλε άλλαναντέραλλά επορκα υτασει στο τέλος το τα
λέμε τις δν έχουμε εδομαθ